♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HERE IN CABLE NEWS WE TRY NOT TO
OVERPROMISE AT THE BOOTH SET
BEGINNING OF THE SHOW, BUT THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES IS
DOING A MARKUP OF ITS
IMPEACHMENT RESOLUTIONS.
WE ARE MONITORING DATA AND WE
WILL BRING THE HIGHLIGHTS AS
THEY HAPPEN LATER IN THE HOUR.
PLUS WE GOT THE TOP MOMENTS FROM
THE DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
TESTIMONY TO THE SENATE WHICH IS
ALSO AHEAD.
FIRST TONIGHT, THANKS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IG REPORT
WE NOW KNOW FOR CERTAIN WHAT
WAS, FOR THOSE PAYING ATTENTION,
FAIRLY OBVIOUS FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
WE NOW KNOW THAT THE
STEELE DOSSIER PLAYED A CENTRAL
ROLE IN THE GENESIS OF THE
BEGINNING OF THE RUSSIA HOAX.
THE DOSSIER WAS USED TO JUSTIFY
EXTENSIVE SPYING ON AN INNOCENT
AMERICAN CITIZEN WHICH WOULD BE
FORMER NAVAL OFFICER IN
ANNAPOLIS GRADUATE CARTER PAGE.
THE TOP TWO LEADERS OF THE FBI
WERE CLOSELY INVOLVED TO DO
THIS.
OTHER POWERFUL PEOPLE KNEW WHAT
WAS HAPPENING AND THEN LIED TO
COVER IT UP LATER.
ALL OF THAT WAS CONFIRMED
YESTERDAY BY THE IG REPORT.
THE REPORT WAS A DISASTER FOR
THE CREDIBILITY OF OUR
BUREAUCRATIC CLASS IN WASHINGTON
BUT IT'S ALSO A BIG, BIG PROBLEM
FOR THE AMERICAN NEWS MEDIA.
THEY WERE EXPOSED AS LIARS AND
KNOW NOTHINGS AS WELL.
WE COULD GIVE YOU A MILLION
EXAMPLES OF THIS BUT WE WILL
GIVE YOU JUST A FEW BECAUSE THEY
PAINT THE PICTURE.
IN EARLY 2018 "WASHINGTON POST"
SHANE HARRIS LECTURED KIM
STRESSFUL OF
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" ABOUT
HOW LITTLE SHE KNEW ABOUT THE
STORY.
YES, SHE WROTE CONDESCENDINGLY,
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS NOT USED AS A
WARRANT.
THEY MAY WONDER HOW WE COULD
HAVE KNOWN THAT SINCE A FISA
WARRANT WAS CLASSIFIED.
HE HAS NEVER EXPLAINED.
BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER, IT WAS
FALSE AND NOW WE KNOW IT'S
FALSE.
BUT HERE'S THE KEY.
PEREZ HAS NOT APOLOGIZED OR EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGED HIS ROLE IN
REPEATING.
DEMOCRACY DIES IN THE DARK, NO.
OR, TAKE NBC NEWS IS SO-CALLED
INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT.
IN THE SUMMER OF 2018, HE
TWEETED THIS "TRUMP IS WRONG
ABOUT CARTER PAGE AND THE
DOSSIER AND THE FISA WARRANT."
EXCEPT IT LOOKS LIKE TRUMP
WASN'T RIGHT ABOUT CARTER PAGE
AND THE DOSSIER AND THE FISA
WARRANT.
AND KEN DELANEY IN WAS
COMPLETELY WRONG.
JIM SHOOT-OUT DID ADMIT THE
STEELE DOSSIER MIGHT HAVE BEEN
USED FOR THE FISA WARRANT.
BUT DON'T BE IMPRESSED.
HE LECTURED READERS THAT "THE
FBI WOULD CORROBORATE
INFORMATION ON ITS OWN BEFORE
USING SUCH INTEL TO JUSTIFY THE
FISA WARRANT.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU CAN BELIEVE
YOUR GOVERNMENT WAGES AND
GENTLEMEN AND ANYONE WHO DOUBTS
THAT IS A BAD PERSON.
OF COURSE, THAT WAS A LIE, TOO.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
JUST THE OPPOSITE HAPPENED.
WE NOW KNOW THAT THE FBI HID
INFORMATION SHOWING THE DOSSIER
WAS FALSE.
THEY DIDN'T CONFIRM THE
INFORMATION, THEY PRETENDED IT
WAS REAL WHEN THEY KNEW IT
WASN'T AND THEY CONTINUE TO USE
IT TO RE-UP THE FISA WARRANT.
TOTALLY DISHONEST BEHAVIOR.
HE WAS WRONG, AT BEST.
DID HE ISSUE A CORRECTION?
NO.
HE WAS TOO BUSY TWEETING AND IT
NANCY PELOSI TWEET.
IT DOES SEEM A LITTLE UNFAIR TO
FOCUS ON JIM SHOOT-OUT.
IT IS MERELY FOLLOWING THE LEAD
OF EVERYONE ELSE WHO HAD SEEN
IT, TRYING TO CONVINCE YOU THAT
THE DOSSIER WAS TOTALLY
IRRELEVANT TO THE FISA WARRANT.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE FOCUSED
ON THE DOSSIER, A LOT OF PEOPLE
WERE FOCUSED ON THE PFIZER.
>> AND NOW REPUBLICANS ARE
TRYING TO CLAIM THAT THE DOSSIER
WAS KEY TO GETTING PFIZER, THE
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT FOR
CARTER PAGE.
THE DEMOCRATS MEMO CLEARLY SHOWS
IT WASN'T THE KEY, IT WAS MORE
TO KEY TO THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY HAVE.
>> EVEN THE EARLIER VERSION OF
THE REDACTED PFIZER
AUTHORIZATION TO ME HAD ENOUGH
INFORMATION IN IT TO INDICATE
THAT THE DOSSIER WAS CERTAINLY
NOT USED AS A PRIMARY SOURCE.
>> Tucker: OUCH.
THAT HASN'T WEATHERED WELL, AS
IT?
EVERYTHING YOU JUST SAW TURNED
OUT TO BE FALSE IF NOT OUTRIGHT
LYING.
THERE IS NO DEBATE ABOUT IT, AND
WE KNOW NOW IT WAS WRONG.
HAS HE RETRACTED IT OR
APOLOGIZE?
THAT'S A RHETORICAL QUESTION.
APOLOGIES REQUIRE INTROSPECTION,
DECENCY AND INTEGRITY EVEN.
THEY ARE BY CONTRAST DOUBLING
DOWN.
WATCHED ON THE MANN EXPLAINED
THAT BY DEFINITION EVERYTHING
SEEN AND REPORTED WAS TRUE.
>> SO HOW IS THE WHITE HOUSE AND
REPUBLICAN PARTY DEALING WITH
THE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT, AND
AN INSPECTOR WILL MAKE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT THAT
DEBUNKED THEIR CONSPIRACY
THEORIES?
GAS LIGHTING.
THERE WAS NO SPYING OF COURSE.
THE FBI OBTAINED PROPER WARRANTS
TO READ THE REPORT.
FACTS FIRST, NONE OF THAT'S
TRUE.
IT FOUND THAT THE LAUNCH OF THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION WAS A
LIKELY SOUND, UNBIASED AND THAT
NO SPYING OCCURRED.
THAT IS THE GOD'S HONEST TRUTH.
READ THE REPORT IF YOU BELIEVE
ME.
>> Tucker: READ THE REPORT,
JUST READ IT.
FOX FIRST.
THAT'S KIND OF HIS MOTTO.
WIZENED OLD NEWS MAN THAT HE IS.
HE CAN'T GET ENOUGH FACTS AND
WHEN IT COMES TO FACTS, HE IS
LIKE A FAT KID AT THE CONCESSION
STAND.
AND YOUR OPINION IT HAS IN
PLACE.
GOVERNOR CUOMO'S BROTHER AGREES
WITH THAT.
UNLIKE YOU HE WENT TO YELL AT
UNIVERSITY AND ADMITTED CLEARLY
BY PLUCK AND CLEVERNESS AND HARD
WORK SO HE'S SMART ENOUGH TO
KNOW LYING WHEN HE SEES IT AND
NOT PARTISAN ENOUGH TO REPORT IT
WITHOUT FEAR OR FAVOR.
WATCH.
>> TRUMP IS A VICTIM.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT WAS WHAT WAS PROMISED FROM
THIS IG'S REPORT.
476 PAGES.
NO TRUMP AS VICTIM.
TRUMP EVEN SAYS THAT THAT'S WHAT
THIS SAYS, IT DOESN'T.
HE'S LYING TO YOU ABOUT THE
REPORT.
PLEASE, DO YOURSELF A FAVOR AND
DO THE HOMEWORK.
HE'S LYING TO YOU.
>> DO THE HOMEWORK DENIES CHRIS
CUOMO.
READ THE IG REPORT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO WONDER.
LET'S BE HONEST HERE, IS CHRIS
CUOMO LIVING UP TO HIS OWN
STANDARDS?
HAS HE ACTUALLY READ THE IG
REPORT?
COME ON NOW, BE HONEST.
OR IS IT POSSIBLE THAT CHRIS
CUOMO'S ASSISTANT PROMISED TO
READ THE IG REPORT, GAVE HIM A
SUMMARY AND THEN GOT STUCK IN A
SUPER LONG HOLIDAY SEASON LINE
AT STARBUCKS AND FORGOT TO DO
IT?
THEN MAYBE IN A LAST MINUTE
PANIC, IS UNDERSTANDABLE, MAY BE
TOLD A FEW WHITE LIES TO CHRIS
CUOMO ABOUT WHAT THE REPORT
ACTUALLY SAID.
MAYBE THAT HAPPENED.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT HAPPENED,
BUT CERTAINLY ONE POSSIBLE
EXPLANATION.
WE DO KNOW THIS.
UNLESS HE IS A PATHOLOGICAL LIA
LIAR, HE DIDN'T ACTUALLY READ
THE IG REPORT.
OTHERWISE HE WOULD NOT HAVE SAT
IN THE TELEVISION STUDIO, AND